لا تزال يعني الاوضاع هادئه جدا في محافظه
معان وت تحديدا في منطقه الحسينيه وفي
باقي محافظات المملكه الهدوء منذ يوم امس
شهد شهدت هذه المناطق احتجاجات واسعه في
عده مناطق في هذه المحافظات همم ولكن
الهدوء همم الذي ساد منذ او بعد همم اصدار
بيان الامن العام بمقتل الضابط الاردني
واصابه اخرين اثنين همم هناك هدوء همم
كامل في همم كافه مناطق المملكه هنا في
منطقه الحسينيه كان هناك تعزيزات امنيه
قبل قليل همم دخلت الى هذه المنطقه الامن
العام اصدر قبل قليل همم
بيان قال فيه ان وحده مكافحه الجرائم
تتابع كل من ينشر خطاب الكراهيه والحظ على
العنف لان كل من ينشر هذه او ينشر هذه
الفيديوهات التي تحرض على العنف وعلى
الاحتجاجات العنيفه سيحال الى القضاء وتم
ايقاف منصه التكتوك في الاردن همم مبدئيا
الى ان يعني لانها لم يعني همم
لم تعد همم يعني او كانت سببا في هذه
الاحتجاجات وكانت سببا في نشر بعض
الفيديوهات المسيئه للاجهزه الامنيه
والمسيئه همم للاحتجاجات السلميه بالحظ
على الحظ على همم
العنف في هذه الاحتجاجات بعد قليل بعد نصف
ساعه من الان تقريبا او على راس الساعه
سيكون هناك مؤتمر صحفي لوزير الداخليه
الاردني مازن الفرايه وايضا
وزير الاتصال الحكومي فيصل الشبول ومدير
الامن العام اللواء عبيد الله المعايطه
للوقوف على كافه تفاصيل الحادثه او حادثه
يوم امس وعلى ما سيجري اعود الى ميدانيا
هنا في هذه المنطقه حيث تم اطلاق النار
على الامن مما ادى الى مقتل الضابط
الاردني وهمم اصابه اخرين اثنين من هذه
المنطقه التي تشاهدينها وهي الاشجار
والمنطقها هذه مقابل همم هذا الشارع تم
اطلاق النار باتجاه الضابط الاردني الذي
كان متواجد هنا في مكان انا همم تم اختباء
الاوقامه همم
بين هذه الاشجار منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
الاجهزه الامنيه وكافه الاجهزه همم
المعنيه ايضا من همم البحث الجنائي وغيره
كان يمسح لهذه المنطقه ومساحه بشكل كامل
للوقوف او وصول الى اي دليل همم همم
لهؤلاء الذين وصفهم همم الامن العام
بالخارجين عن القانون المجتمع الاردني
وكافه شرائح المجتمع الاردني نبدت
واستنكرت هذه الحادثه وطالبت الامن العام
بالوصول لهؤلاء المجرمين نعم